and i'm mindful
not only of our need to protect human
life
but our imperative
to protect the nhs
and those services um which we all rely
having considered the consultation
responses the advice of my officials and
nhs leaders including the chief
executive of the nhs i have concluded
that all those working in the nhs and
social care will have to be vaccinated
we must avoid preventable harm and
protect patients in the nhs protect
colleagues in the nhs
and of course protect the nhs itself
only those colleagues who can show that
they
they are fully vaccinated against covert
19 can be employed or engaged in those
settings
there will be two key exemptions
one for those who don't have
face-to-face contact with patients
and the second for those that are
medically exempt
these requirements will apply across
health and wider social care settings
that are regulated by the care quality
commission
mr deputy speaker
we're not the only country in the world
that has taken such steps there are
similar policies for specific workers in
other countries including the united
states france and italy
mr deputy speaker this decision doesn't
mean that i don't recognize concerns
about workforce pressures this winter
and indeed beyond
as a result of some people perhaps
choosing to leave their job because of
the decision that we've taken of course
i recognize that
it's with this in mind that we've chosen
for the condition not to come into force
until 12 weeks after parliamentary
approval
allowing time for remaining colleagues
to make the positive choice to protect
themselves of those around them and time
for workforce planning